Last time on Tuesday, we
was talking about, um,
the use of the word Nigger,
uh, by various people.
I'm in contact sometimes, uh,
trying to be a true realizing,
um, sometimes obviously agonized by
trying to the do this guy's have fact.
Uh, but uh, sometimes by one's
neighbors, sometimes by oneself,
but, um, always, uh, in the
kind is nontrivial usage.
Um,
so today we're turning to the other side
of the phenomenon and thinking about
what it means to inhabit
that adjective Negro,
whether it means to embrace
that as once identity.
So, um, the, a list of Joel Christmas,
part of the story of light in August,
um,
is really about what it means for
somebody to choose to be black race.
So it's very important to recognize
that this is a volitional act,
is a decision, active
conscious decision. Um,
but in that sense is also
about someone poise. Um,
onto contrary possibilities
don't Christmas could be
either black or he could be
like,
so the either or a possibility is
something that actually becomes quite
important in American literature.
The side of the farmer.
So I just wanted to talk about
one other word published,
very close to like an honors
plant, never last. And, um,
as we can see now lost in
herself in someone, uh,
who could go either way. Um,
it's just classified as, um,
African American because
of the one drop rule.
So if you have the slightest bit of
African American heritage of classified as
black, so the black raider,
um, but she, you know,
really could be anything.
Um,
and in fact sheet there's no clear
and after I'm in mid career, um,
and just completely vanish from
public and until she was fun there.
And, um, there was a lot of the,
is that actually as she was
passing on those years, uh,
when she disappeared and
she wrote the novel, uh,
calm housing about two black women,
one Tuesday to be married to
someone who is identified with,
are black and the others using
to pass as a white woman.
But I'm not succeeding
at this, not being, uh,
very happy with that
decision. Um, so passing, um,
this was publishing in putting us are
very close to let an artist and um,
in, as we can see from the book cover is
really about the choice of someone who
looks completely wait,
who is classify as black,
but who chooses to behave as a white
person live the life of a white person.
So, um, in fall,
no in one way see is
also a kind of passing.
So let's not forget that Ashley is very
much similar to the dynamics and Ella
Lawson's passing.
It is someone,
a man who looks as white as the woman
here who actually is initially classified
as white but then chooses in spite of his
outward appearance to embrace the life
of black men.
So it is
passing into the opposite direction.
It is self blackening or white
person blackening himself.
There's no way you can,
and there's interior,
but at least he can try to black and
black and his inside try to black and his
emotions, his choice of
companions and all the rest of it.
So this is what Joe
Christmas decides to do. Um,
when he starts on this run down this
long street that goes from the south to
Chicago, um, to the north
and analysts for 15 years,
he was on this street.
Um,
and that's what happens to him when
he's on this 15 year long street.
He lived with me, Bruce shunning
white people. He eat with them,
slapped with them, belligerent,
unpredictable, uncommunicative.
He now lives as man and wife with a
woman who is assembled and Emily coughing
and they'd, he would lie in bed beside
her sleepers beginning to breathe.
Do you and how he would do it.
Deliberately feeling even watching is
what chess arched deeper and deeper within
this room cage trying
to breathe into himself,
the dark order to dark and inscrutable
thinking and being of Negroes with each
sort of Spiration separation and trying
to expel from himself the way blood and
the way thinking and being and all
the while his nostrils at the older,
when she was trying to make his own
with waiting and taught Watson is whole
being arrive and the string with
physical outreach as spiritual deny.
So this is an incredible
in a status of self black.
Some of the group doesn't
have to be black to the,
against every thing in him has sends
us from our sense of sight and sense of
touch.
Everything again is everything in him.
Even though every endothelium
is revolving, again,
it's being classified and as
black and associating with blacks,
that's what he chooses to do. So it
was a very, very complicated, um,
kind of psychology. Usually when
somebody identifies with someone who's,
they're not usually obviously identified
with us because they believe like that
identity,
but in this case is absolute though
than of being black and at the same time
deciding to be black and stuff.
So this is a much more complex
psychology that we've seen in this novel.
And I think to understand this,
um,
I think we need to borrow the terminology
from someone who talks about what it
costs double consciousness
services. Um, uh,
W e B Dubois, um, um,
very important thinker.
I'm an activists from
the 19th century to 20th.
It's a bit 20th century.
Um,
and he wrote a book called
the souls of black folk,
which you as probably heard of, um, came
up by the wall before light in August.
And um,
this is what he says about blacks.
Let's not forget he's talking about
blacks, people who love black. Um,
this is what he's asked about the kind
of complicated consciousness of the
blacks have.
It is the peculiar sensation,
this double consciousness,
this sense of always looking at
oneself through the eyes of others,
of measuring one.
So by the tape of the world
that those on in the news,
content and pity when I'm with
fuse is tumors and American,
a Negro, two souls, two thoughts,
two unreconciled strivings two
warring ideas in one dark body.
So, um, this is this, keep
looking at this person.
A person who looks black has no choice
but to inhabit this double consciousness,
both to be aware of oneself as oneself,
you know,
having a completely internal
relation to oneself,
but at the same time having another views
superimposed upon oneself because of
the way other people are looking at you.
So it is this doubleness one is looking
at one through and supplies and then in
voluntarily through the
eyes of other people.
But we shouldn't forget that in fact,
Joe Christmas doesn't
look like the black one.
He looks like the male counterpart
to this white looking woman.
So is even more complicated than
what two boys is suggesting.
It's not the double consciousness
of an obviously black man,
but the double consciousness of a white
looking person who even though he's
really pow, but blackness
nonetheless embraces blackbirds.
So it is just, you know, it's, it's,
it's double consciousness redoubled um,
in,
in terms of this degree of complexity.
Um,
and today I like to talk about
this kind of readable, double,
double consciousness. The involvement, um,
along three last January.
One is obviously the importance
of the light and shadow,
which is advertised strong
ties in the title. Um,
the other is something that
we've sort of been talking about,
which is the relation between at a single
individual and then the population of
a group or motors here today.
That's what I like to introduce. Um,
and then something that
we've been talking about. Um,
all the way through about the question
John [inaudible] and whether the,
the dynamics between comedy and tragedy.
Um,
but let's start with also, um, given this,
this configuration, um, I like
to look at three characters,
basically the two ends of the spectrum.
And then the point, um, I think that,
you know,
is to answer the spectrum would be would
be Joel prisoners and Lehman Grove. Um,
one tragic figure in the comic figure.
Um,
and between the two of them I like to put
now the furthest they go with just the
reverend hightower.
Um,
we've been talking about the revenant
and hire talent in various contexts,
but I like to bring him to bear now on
the two obvious protagonists of light in
August. Um, but first styling
with Joe Christmas, um,
like to talk about three moments,
actually more than three,
but three clusters and moments, um, uh,
revolving around the APP.
A striking match is so the,
so obviously a pattern,
the symbolic pattern, uh,
revolving around that act that I think
is really worth thinking about the three
of them in sequence and
in the interrelations. Um,
so the first instance of strike,
striking or manage is,
um, is when he's contemplating,
um, killing Joanna.
So Christmas lit the cigarette and
snapped the match to what the open door
watching the flame vanish in there.
Then he was listening for
the night trivial sound,
which their match with me
when they struck the floor.
And then this theme to
him that he heard it.
Then his thing to him studying on the
card in a dark room that he was hearing.
And myriad sounds of no
greater volume of voices,
murmurs,
whispers of trees,
darkness of people,
his own voice other than is evocative of
names and times and places which he had
been conscious of his life without
knowing which worries life thinking God
and me not knowing that too,
he could see it like a blended sentence,
foodborne and really debt.
God loves me to let the
feeling and whether my owners
of last year's billboard,
God,
me too.
So it isn't just an incredible acid.
Um,
and I just want to say some obvious things
about it and then come back to it. Um,
but this, the striking of the match
and then the dying out of the match.
So literally the light dying up.
But well there's also an interesting
is that Ashley is the light guys out.
Then it becomes a completely
all the tree, um, moment.
Um, is all about the
sounds that come to, um,
to Joe prisoners out of worries
is, is he hears it, the light,
the visual,
um,
tableau completely gives
away to an arbitrary the
soundscape bits of questions.
Um,
and then there's this weird kind
of emergence of the kind of,
um, his own theology. Right. You know,
we've been talking about importance
of Calvin, um, last time,
um, and the play at the repetition of
the name Calvin in light in August. Um,
and hear this,
this obvious and vocation of his relation
to God and what it means to repeat
that line. Lanka, those me
too. So just want to point
out is obvious things, but uh,
because this is the last class, um, I
thought that, you know, would be good to,
to bring back some other one. The
other two others. So just to, um,
the obvious detail,
I've gone appearing on the bill of
what we actually have seen exactly this
before and the great
gas bed. Um, and I said,
God knows what you've been doing.
Everything you've been doing this is, um,
uh, um, make them, as I'm
talking to George Wilson,
Mattos a husband,
I'm standing behind the,
and you make a mistake with a shock that
he was looking at the eyes of the after
Tj at cover,
which had just emerged pale and
enormous from us and solving made.
So as George Wilson at the moment,
when he is on his starting out
on this quest to kill the killer,
what do you think the person who
needs things kills is why? Um,
and pointing to this God on the
billboard as the authority in that.
Alrighty. Um, to justify his, the
mission that's just beginning.
Um, the, the other way in which
fixture will also come into play.
It's obvious later dinette links
between the visual and the auditory.
So this you talked about before
about the essence voice for a moment,
but last sunshine fell with romantic
affection upon a gluing fares.
Who've always compelled me. Four with
breakfast. Lee as I listen, and a girl,
the ish like discerning,
heard with, lingering regret,
my children leaving a pleasant street
at that rate. So it's quality of voice.
Describe in terms of the visual image.
And finally the great Gatsby and the great
self made man in American literature,
but describe by Fitzgerald as
a quasi religious stuff making.
The truth was that Jay Gaspe of worst
eight long island sprang from his platonic
conception of himself. He
was a son of God, a phrase,
which if it means anything,
it means just that the,
he must be about his father's business,
the servers of a vast
vulgar [inaudible] building.
So he invented himself,
just the sort of Jay Gatsby for the 17
year old boy would be likely to invent.
And to this conception, he
was faithful to it. Now.
So it is very hard to ignore the central
reality of religion in both the great
Gatsby and, and light innocuous. Um,
and the case of the great Gatsby.
Um,
the religious language is really used
to underwrite the special kind of stuff
making and what it means
to be the son of God, um,
in the 20th century and in
the base of environment. Um,
and that's the kind of some
of making that, um, that,
that their first was talking a relatively
non racialized even though we're,
that there's a little bit of
race in the Great Gatsby as well.
So against that, that, uh,
example of Fitzgerald, this
is the one more time, um,
at what farmer is doing with exactly
that configuration, that billboard,
the interplay between the visual and
auditory and some in vocation of God.
Um,
it seems that when the light dies out,
when we saw the only relation to
life is by way of a death match,
right?
That meshed.
And then if it hits the ground and then
the light goes out completely and it's,
that we get is all the sounds,
then come to Dr. Smith and he becomes an
involuntary strictly passive recipient
of Sam's.
I come to him and that really is the
central function of Joel Christmas with
Todd [inaudible].
We've talked before about how passive
he is that his school as an actor,
then a recipient of either the goodwill
or in this case the ill will come in
from other people. Um, so he
really is a blank slate, um,
that on wish other people,
the entire community, um,
can write the collective signature.
Um,
he really is the bearer of,
it's not a very good mellophone concerning
that we're looking at and monitoring
image, but just the switch
to visual image briefly.
Um, here's the bearer of the collectors,
the nature of that community.
So the transition from light to darkness
in this moment and the transition from,
uh,
from the input coming into the eye and
the [inaudible] ear is the increasing or
the dramatized positivity
of Joel prisoners. The,
he's really completely a blind patient
that everyone else writes the ds onto.
But there's this further complication
because this is a racialized landscape.
It seems to give us a racialize version
of a Calvinist theology that we talking
about last time. So just wonder,
think about what it means that, okay,
the first item of size, um, costume,
worst God perhaps been here,
not doing that too.
And then God loves me to repeat it twice.
It's almost as if the only thing George
Christmas is true about is that God
loves other people. That is an
undisputed statement, right?
So God loves other people,
maybe got lost, everyone else,
maybe he lost me too.
So they can be more devastating.
Um,
self reflection or speculation about,
uh,
yourself is that every hour,
everyone hours come before you.
You basically you are an after thought
and maybe not even an afterthought in gas
mine.
Um,
and even if it is an after thought it
was written on gas consciousness is
written like this, those failure
than weather leathers of last year's,
they overboard, um, that
you're that unimportant,
that negligible to God.
So it definitely is a,
um, interesting, uh,
racialized variation on predestination.
So just,
it's worth going back to Calvin for
that reason and see why and actually who
lands itself so readily to this particular
negative kind of revitalization.
Uh, last time we talked
about original sin. So,
and so this is another very famous
statement coming from Calvin
on predestination. Um,
and you know this nobody more up front
than Calvin about predestination of what
it means by eternal and immutable counsel.
God has ones for or determine those who
he would admit to salvation and those
whom he would condemn to destruction
to those who hate the Vost,
to condemnation the gate of how the
game of life is close by Justin.
And we rent, rent, EU reprehensible,
but in comprehensible Joshlynn.
So the game of life is close by just,
and you reprehensible in
comprehensible judgment.
There's no way you can quarrel with God
is his decision.
He decides that you are
going to be condemned. Um,
it doesn't make any sense to you.
Basically, if you are the condemn, um,
you can make any sense of it
is completely incomprehensible.
But at the same time,
if you'll Calvin is you also have to
believe that it is a reprehensible,
that God has every right to condemn you,
even though it's from your point of view,
it seems completely arbitrary.
So that really is the
meaning of predestination in
particular interpretation of
a rage,
racialized context is that to be black
is to be predestined in that particular
ways.
Always to comes that always to be an
after thought and maybe even less than an
afterthought in the mind of God.
And that is what Joe Fritz
was metaphorically as well
as pragmatically chooses
to give him his own sense of
being so negligible in the world.
Um,
so you know,
that that would be one interpretation
of why he chooses to black and himself,
even though he doesn't have to.
Um,
so this is thoughtless version
of predestination itself.
Black names of white looking man.
Um,
it completely honors
the logic of the gate,
the flight being closed by just an
you reprehensible, but incompetence,
judgment and it's always
under the shadow of race.
So I would say that the pod of light
in August that is associated with Joe
Christmas, it's very much the regime of
shadows. Um, and thoughtfulness. Bachelor,
quite heavy handed about
how often in, you know, the,
we've said the original title I
was nine in August was dog house.
It can also be the shadows
of augers because so much
of the book is really about
shadows. So, um, and the
shadows tend to emerge,
um,
in the context of striking a match.
So let's go onto the next moment.
That's next episode of Joe Christmas
striking [inaudible] turning on the,
um, lighting aware. Um,
this is the moment after the,
the dialogue that we've looked at last
time of Joanna offering to send him into
a black to stand with a black lawyer
and turning over our funds to him. Um,
and then the next thing that she asked
him to do is to kneel with her and pray.
So this is all in that context.
Like the land.
She said it won't need an invite.
He said like the man,
no,
he said he's too for the bed.
He held him razor in his head,
but it was not open yet,
but she did not speak again.
And then his body seem to walk away from
him if when to the table and his hands
late, the racer on the table
and found blam as match.
So very heavy handed.
An alienation of Joe Christmas
from his bar, the rate,
it's not jog Christmas
that's doing the walking,
his body seem to walk away from him.
It's not Joe Christmas who was uh,
laying the razor on the table as his
hands that was doing it and his hands that
is striking the right the lamb.
So it's just uh,
the ash and kind of the strictly just
from the front man of barley part and the
consequence.
So just highlighting the other passively
of dog business themselves and serves
individual front mounted bypass health
agency but not dope business as a whole.
Um,
the consequence of the
lighting this lab is this,
this is what we see when
the land is that um,
he had today's see something
else that casts a shadow on warp.
It held an all star single action cap
and ball revolver almost as long and
heavier than the small rival.
But the shadow of it and off her arm and
hand on the wall did not waver at all.
The shadow of both monsters,
the car hammer,
monstrous back haute and
viciously boys like arch,
head of the snake. It in that way for
them. And their eyes do not waver.
Ally there were as still as the round
black ring of the pistol muscle,
there was no heat and no theory,
but he was not watching them.
He was watching the shadow
pistol on the while.
He was watching the cock shadow
of her hand slipped away.
I mean it's almost as if it's irrelevant,
it's actually coming up.
The most important thing is
the play of that shadow on war.
But we don't do know that the shadow
is produced by that revolver. Um,
but here we have actually
the symmetry of weaponry.
So geography is come fully equipped.
He has the razor in his head even though,
um,
is not open and Joanna has to revolve and
are ready and she thinks that is ready
to go.
And that's what Joe Christmas is seeing.
So this is the outcome of that particular
relationship that is completely under
the shadow raised [inaudible] with
and they are with Nivo or Negro League
reliever.
Um,
bad relationship is completely
under the shadow of race.
So this is actually the earliest moment
which talks about race and it's a curse
as an internal course,
as the equivalent of predestination.
But after that last thing, to see
them for the first time novice people,
but as a thing,
a shadow in which I live with
all white people or other people,
I thought with all the children coming
forever and never run into the wall white
with a black shadow already falling
upon them before they drew a graph.
And I seem to see the black
shadow in the shape of a cross.
I'm not even going to read you
the whole thing you guys remember,
this message is very much the vocation,
the black shadow as the modern
incarnation of the Calvin,
this doctrine of original sin and
occurs the falls upon you, uh,
before you were even born,
before when you were a baby,
before you've done anything,
even before you won,
when you're in your mother's womb, that
shadow of Israeli fall into the party.
So it's a very,
very extreme version of count.
The carbon is the allergy and bright.
Here.
We also see it not only as theology but
as dramatic action as the shadow of that
historical, um, on the wall.
And we now know the, the final,
uh, moment of striking to
Christmas striking badge.
Um,
then he paused and he struck a match
and examine the pistol in the puny dying
glare,
the match burned.
And whether they still seem to see
the Asian thing with is too low.
The chambers,
the one upon which they have
or haven't really fallen in,
which had not exploded the other upon
wish no hammer had fallen further behind,
which I hammer had been
planned for for her.
And from the is that his arm came back
and through your hurt the pistol crash
once through the undergrowth,
then there was no sound again for her.
And for me.
So this is the basically the
tragic and a Latin artist.
There's no denying the
importance of tragedy, uh,
and is, uh, is, you know,
it depends on how much weight
we assigned to the job.
Trismus and to put that in
the section of the novel. Um,
if we were to give primacy
to that session, then the,
the cemetery of weapon as
the razor and the pistol, um,
than the boat,
the boat chambers loaded into pistol,
that she really means, uh, for
the two of them to die together.
This is the appropriate
for a tragic narrative,
even though Christmas doesn't
die from that. Uh, nonetheless,
the stage is really sad for
that particular tragic outcome.
Um, so there's really not
a whole lot more, you know,
it couldn't be any other outcome.
There could be no,
no other ending, uh, for
children's and Joanna,
either one of them would have to die with
the two of them would have to die. Um,
but there's really no other thought and
can't really think of any other ending
for the two of them. Um, so let's,
but thank God they're not the
only ones in light in August.
So we're beginning to move,
um,
to somewhat to the other side was
the other side of the spectrum. Um,
and,
uh,
actually a very interesting transitional
figure about someone who's at mid
midpoint between Joe Prisoners and
leader growth is high tower. Um,
and um, the as the, the, the
image of the light and shadow, um,
and the kind of contest between light and
shadow is also the visual landscape in
which hightower is situated.
Um,
so this is the moment when baron bunch,
um,
and enjoy Christmas grandparents at
this point we used to pay related,
um, but, but basically Byron Bunch, um,
go into hightower and begging him to
tell a lie so that Joe Christmas can have
an alibi. So bar inside is really
your word again as Joel grounds,
if you would just say that
he was with you that night,
that will be better, stronger evidence
than a, and then coming home from jail,
Bruh.
So high pug could have told a lie
and the lynching would have happened,
but this is what he does because now
like how is shouting I won't do it.
I won't.
With his hands raised and clench
his face when his lived through,
lifted.
The pan is cleansed and rotting teeth
from about which the sagging of flabby and
Publico Flash Fos away.
Suddenly his voice rises high again.
Get out of these screams, get
out of my house, go my house.
Now he falls forward onto the desk,
his face between his expanded
arms and his claimed.
This fits as to two people
moving ahead of him.
Baron looks back from the door,
he sees that hightower has not moved his
ball head and has expanded and clenched
fist of arms while I four in the
pool of light from the shaded plan.
Um,
so this particular visual image suggests
that hightower's completely poise
between Biden Shadow, um, this light,
but it's coming from the shaded lab and
he's given an opportunity actually to do
something significant in well
to have saved two Christmas.
We'll have been a significant decrease
in the life for some of you actually has
not done a lot of significant
things. Um, you know,
does it very, his life could have
been much more consequential.
And in fact, it hasn't been all
that consideration. So Sally,
Joe Christmas would have been
a consequential action. Um,
but hide hell just cannot bring himself
to do with all kinds of reasons.
So we can speculate why
he chooses not to do it,
but that is the moment when his voice
is very high as befitting his name,
the high tower.
But what the very highs voice is doing
is turning away this opportunity.
I think all of us will have different
decisions whether or not to lie that over.
His decision is not alive and to allow
the violence to erupt as everyone can see
that it's about to. Um,
but this is not the,
so this is the moment when his sort
of 'em in the satellite from the ship,
poor machine, wham. But this, um,
and another possibility for height,
how that comes.
Actually we five page after that.
Um,
so far that actually I will say is quite
gentle towards high tower in terms of
the final place, um, given to him, um,
in the story in the novel.
Um,
so we know that once before hightower
how tried with deliver the baby. Right?
So like we have a black woman and he
spit the doctors most common Dr Raj to
banks who hide out the lose
the baby and the baby is dead.
And then the rumors go around the
town that the baby is his. So, so, uh,
it turns out that he actually gets
a second chance to deliver a baby.
Of course we know whose baby it is,
um,
but he gets to deliver the baby because
the doctor also arrived too late the
second time.
So the doctor arrived too late this time.
Also,
Byron had to wait for him to dress virals
Santa fast adopter Barron than to wait
for him to dress.
He was an oldish man now and Farsi and
somewhat disgruntled and having been
awaken at this hour.
Then he had to hunt for the switch key
to his car or was your captain and a
small metal strong box. The key to which
in turn he could not find that once.
So when they reached the cabin that lasts,
the ease was primrose color and there
was already handled this with some of
summer and again,
two men both older now met at
the door of one room cabin.
The professional having
lost that again to them too.
First he enter the door to Dr. Hood,
the infant.
So it is crucial that
this is a repetition.
This is a replay of an earliest scenario.
Fuckwit Amazon's is this over again,
it's the second time growth too
late this time also also and again,
so it turns out that actually the second
time around makes all the difference in
the world because at this time high
tower is evil to deliver the baby
successfully.
This is actually the consequential action
that he manages to do that is granted
him. He's not granted the, the on the, um,
bravery or you know,
I don't even know what word to use
for if he had chosen to lie. He,
he's not granting that whatever
mental ability or mental Thomas,
uh, to, to lie to life or
for, um, for Joel Christmas.
But he has ran or something that Ashley
is both more uncontroversial and with an
obviously the night outcome to delivery
of a baby where the professional,
the doctor is to like this time too.
So it turns out that Faulkner
has given us not only,
and that is why the double consciousness
is we doubled or maybe we doubled again
in late in August,
is that there are two
meanings to be in second,
um, in Joe Christmases, usage,
God loves me to be in second means that
basically you and nobody that you are
nothing that you'd council nothing at all.
You're always going to be an
afterthought for me too. Um,
that's what being stabbed is,
means losing out and maybe not
even having the dignity of losing.
I would just meaning being
a non contender really, um,
in a field where everyone else
is going to be ahead of you.
Being in that camp contender is what
being sad and having the word to attach to
you.
Um,
but that's not the only meaning
of two or in a variation.
Awesome.
So the second time when we see that in
the case of high tower to darker arrive
to make this time also
second actually means a second chance
that you messed up the first time around.
You know,
he didn't actually really wasn't so much
messing up a meeting or some ladies are
just born there. Um, but the,
I is with some messing up,
you know, it wasn't a completely
satisfied, it wasn't, that's fine.
Outcome wasn't acceptable
outcome to most people. Um,
so you messed up the first time around,
you get a second chance
to do it one more time.
So being second,
Ashley completely supports that sat
in usage and that is why to my mind,
um,
hightower decision and put in mid point
between Joe Christmas and the Grove,
is that his athlete ticking on us,
um,
halfway,
and the direction of a much more
affirmative view of, you know,
one as possible, um, much more
further to the view of the world.
Um,
but it is important to recognize that
this is actually a completely accidental
development, right? There's no reason,
no logical reason why the
doctors should arrive too late.
And it's only because the
doctor arrives two ways,
then I targets to deliver the baby.
The doctor arrives, two emphases.
Oh wait to be working out
in the middle of the night,
can find it's key to the car. Um,
all this accidental development,
um, contribute to, and
the doctors had told her,
other than the fact that
he's a at once before,
he really is an absolute stranger to
novel. He's such an original character.
So third,
second chance coming to tie tower comes
to him by virtue of the pregnancy and
childbirth of a total stranger in a
row and the exit download weightness of
another accidental person,
the doctor.
So we're beginning to get into, um, uh,
an arena where is really not
high towers action alone,
but the combined action
of all these other people,
um,
many of whom are strangers to him,
it is the combined action of all
these people that produce an outcome.
So this is a romantic interview. Some, um,
theoretical speculation on
this point and um, James,
uh, through a Wiki is, I'm a
staff writer for the New Yorker.
Um, and he, while back, he wrote
a book and you're not like that,
but that thing five,
10 years ago wrote a book
called the wisdom of crowds,
which actually got a lot of attention
when it came up. And his basic argument,
um, is that, um,
that the collective decision, uh, or,
or just the collective, um, congenital,
anyone when this is inflammation,
the collective conjection
collected guesswork,
but abrogation of gases from a lot of
people that aggregation is always going to
be closer to the truth than the
single gas was single individuals.
So it's actually a kind of complicated
mathematical argument is about
aggregation of conjecture being better,
having a much higher likelihood of
being closer to the truth. So it's,
even though it doesn't talk
about statistics, actually,
it's very statistical and this is over
thinking that is about chances and
likelihood themselves.
Um, the other book, um,
that is also relevant and
as it has the title, um,
here is by Michael called and
told me angry, um, is, um,
burden you with a food substance.
So that argument. But this one, um,
I mean it's really not not
about what we're talking
about. There is one line, um,
that is relevant to what
we've been talking about. Um,
which is about the thinking
about what the meaning, um,
now to two could have for them mounted
to is the cooperators conversions of
subjects only the Malibu to through
its practical experimentation,
we're off of the models and determine
when and how the possible becomes the
real. So it has some, um,
has some resemblance to
this road wiki argument,
which is that it is about how the
possible can they come to Rio.
And it turns out that the
collective conjecture,
that amplification of individual
guesswork or individual,
the aggregation of action from long people
would put us in closer contact to how
the possible can become too real.
Um,
so these are the two sort
of can turn free, um,
lines of thinking about Ruth and about
human populations as opposed to human
individuals as the Asians of history.
Um,
it turns out that actually there's also
a 19th century precedent for a farmer.
And we're so used to thinking of
the scarlet letter as a combination,
as the bigotry of puritans.
But let's not forget actually the Hobsons
if very important statement about now
with you that brands completely countered
or stereotypical vision of Paradise
when,
and I'm instructed mounted to
attempts to see with his eyes,
it is exceedingly apt to be deceived when,
however iPhones this judgment as it
usually does and the intuitions of this
great and warm hot,
the conclusions that attained often.
So proof and so airing as to possess
the character truce supernaturally with
you.
Um,
it's an astonishing statement from the
scholars are saying that in fact that the
great and warm hot is not the attribute
of the single individual than in fact
the human heart in his
individual embodiment is likely
to have lots and lots of
shadows.
And,
and the only way that those shadows can
be relatively to activated is when we
think that the aggregate me, I think
that's the really interesting theory.
I'm just offering it to
you as possible. Um, so,
but I do think that this is
what Farbman um, things in his,
the use of tools, strangers,
um, doctors, you know,
people who have no relation to
one another and live longer.
So basically his notion often now the
two is that this random isis statistical
population though and this chance there.
Um,
and this is the moment,
and I think this is an extreme moment,
um, in light in August when right before
the killing, actually Joe Christmas,
this essentially more it get,
it's early,
doesn't go with the deed that follows.
But this is what's often gives us in the
land and suspension of augers intuition
nighters about two full income.
It seems to engender as rounds
out for thing or like a halo.
The Halo is full of phases.
The phases are not shame with suffering
last shape with anything, not horror,
pain or even reproach.
They are peaceful as though they have
escape and apotheosis is only is about
them. So I don't need to
talk anymore about that.
Just that the halo is not the hill.
I'm a single phase in this for our faces.
Um,
and it is,
that's the reason why he goes right back
to how you starts out talking about the
kindness of strangers and there's kindness
of strangers is not even our agonized
by everything that has happened in
between patient one of the light in August
and the last page, the last pages
of like the kindness of a stranger.
Yes.
It has to recognize and take into account
and fully and knowledge and put in the
foreground the cruelty of one's neighbors.
No question about it.
It has to encompass all of that,
but the kindness of strangers we means.
And so he's totally happy to bring in
personal never before mansion in,
in August in the last pages of the novel,
the lives in the eastern part
of the state of Virginia repair.
And do your who recently made a trip
into Tennessee to guess an obese as a
furniture which had
bought by correspondence
completely extraneous detail,
um, at the end of the novel. And the
reason this furniture dealer, um,
is in the picture somewhere is that
he is there to witness this ongoing
courtship train being a growth and,
uh,
Barton bunch,
so less see what farmer's
things about marriage.
Um, and it turns out that
he actually has thought,
given some thought to his rival,
the relation between the two
of them are not always, uh,
relations with cordial.
Uh,
so it goes right into [inaudible]
it outright in any way.
Poor bloke to have to marry three times
to find, know that marriage is a failure.
Apparently man can be cured of trucks,
gambling,
biting his nails and picking his nose,
but not often narrate.
This is what we're addicted to his
marriage. It doesn't matter. And you know,
you've failed thousand hundred,
you still won't get married.
So given the fact is totally cleared I
evaluation of the outcome of marriage,
Dawson, the fact that it's just
going to be an ongoing addiction, um,
we can maybe go,
we should not be surprised by what
comes to the end of Pflag Naugles.
And I just want this, when you're
talking about him in wintertime,
remind you that we spend this kind of
structured format with the structure,
right. And they, um,
the phone about those,
he lay flat on the Brown pine needles,
fall in the forest,
his chin on his phone at arms
beginning of the novel, and is awful.
He could feel his heart beating
against upon you, those little,
the forest and being of light in August,
probably at the beginning
and ending beginning,
although I have not been
quite a month on the road,
I'm ready in Mississippi and then offline,
all those hail and then
coming from Alabama for two
months and now it's already
Tennessee.
So it is Lena [inaudible] candy on the
kindness of strangers and county on the
statistical side than to every Lucas Bush.
There will always be a battery punch
because marriage is an addiction.
So that's one comment.
Thank you very
[inaudible].